Let's see together what is the training
strategy of the WordPiece algorithm
and how it performs the
tokenization of a text once trained
WordPiece is a tokenization algorithm introduced
by Google. It is used for example by Bert.
To our knowledge, the code of Word
Pieces has not been open sourced,
so we base our explanations on our own
interpretation of the published literature.
What is the training strategy of
WordPiece? Similarly to the BPE algorithm,
WordPiece starts by establishing an initial
vocabulary composed of elementary units
and then increases this vocabulary to the
desired size. To build the initial vocabulary,
we divide each word in the training corpus
into the sequence of letters that make it up.
As you can see, there is a small subtlety:
we add a 2 hashtags in front of the letters
that do not start a word. By keeping
only one occurrence per elementary unit
we now have our initial vocabulary. We will
list all the existing pairs in our corpus.
Once we have this list, we will calculate
a score for each of these pairs.
As for the BPE algorithm, we will
select the pair with the highest score.
Taking for example the first pair composed
of H and U. The score of a pair is simply
equal to the frequency of appearance of
the pair divided by the product of the
frequency of appearance of the first token by
the frequency of appearance of the second token.
Thus at a fixed frequency
of appearance of the pair,
if the subparts of the pair are very frequent
in the corpus then this score will be decreased.
In our example, the pair "hu" appears 4 times, the
letter "h" 4 times and the letter u 4 times. This
gives us a score of 0.25. Now that we know how to
calculate this score, we can do it for all pairs.
We can now add to the vocabulary
the pair with the highest score,
after merging it of course! And now we can
apply this same fusion to our split corpus.
As you can imagine, we just have to repeat the
same operations until we have the vocabulary at
the desired size! Let's look at a few more steps
to see the evolution of our vocabulary and the
length of the splits getting shorter. Now that we
are happy with our vocabulary, you are probably
wondering how to use it to tokenize a text. Let's
say we want to tokenize the word "huggingface".
WordPiece follows these rules: We will look for
the longest possible token at the beginning of
our word. Then we start again on the remaining
part of our word. And so on until we reach the
end! And that's it, huggingface is divided
into 4 sub-tokens. ßThis video is about to
end, I hope it helped you to understand
better what is behind the word WordPiece!